A few years ago,
I suddenly had a lot of extra time
to spend staring out the window.
Maybe you did a little bit of that, too,
in quarantine, at the start
of the pandemic.
And while we were locked down,
I got kind of fascinated
with what was still moving out there.
Like the local crows,
who went on with their normal commute
down the side of the mountain
every morning.
And up again every evening
at crow quitting time.
(Laughter)
Birds of prey came out every day
and made their rounds.
I'm using a process here
called photo stacking,
where you take multiple pictures
from a fixed point over time
and layer them into one
composite photograph.
Photo stacking is a way to show
the trails of things like stars,
fireflies, athletes, airplanes,
pretty much anything that moves.
It's a way to make the shape
of those movements visible.
Most of these have between
500 and 2,000 layers.
They take a long time to build,
and a lot of that time is spent just
experimenting with which layers to keep in
and which to leave out of the final image.
Here, a group of pelicans
came in from one side
and noticed something
intriguing in the water.
Then another group came in
from the other side
and circled around to check it out.
So this isn't one moment frozen in time
like a traditional photograph,
but something more like a story
told in two dimensions
with layers of the fourth dimension.
Kind of.
Looking at flight trails this way,
you really notice some of the rhyming
patterns that repeat everywhere in nature,
like waves of sound or water
or spiraling galaxies,
whirlpools and storms.
And sometimes they seem
to sort of sketch out other things
that are usually invisible to us.
Like the thermal updrafts
that hawks and vultures ride on,
finding even the smallest patches
of turbulence in the air to carry them.
While I was working on these,
I learned that some vultures
are so good at this
that they can soar that way
without flapping their wings at all
for hours.
Which has to be the most meditative way
there is to look for carrion.
(Laughter)
And this is what it looks like
to navigate by shouting.
Bats are characterized as either
whisperers or shouters,
and we're lucky that the range
of our hearing ends
right about where their voices begin
because the shouts
can get up to 140 decibels,
as loud as a jet engine.
What we call silence
is just the limit of our hearing.
I love to think about that,
and about how most other creatures,
from European moles to rainbow trout,
find their way by wavelengths
of light or sound
or fields of electricity or magnetism
that our senses just aren't set up for.
And that those are just the ways
that we know about.
In the 1930s,
the British ornithologist Edmund Selous
studied flocks of starlings,
moving together as if they had one mind
and wrote a book on his conclusion
that the birds must be psychic.
And, you know, there's still
no evidence that they're not.
But we now know
that they follow each other
with a split-second lag time
that's just too short
for our human sense of time.
And maybe for some predators,
like the peregrine falcon
in the middle there.
So these are pictures of group decisions
made at a speed that makes them
invisible to us.
Pictures of the hidden intelligence
in what might look at first random
or even chaotic.
Reminders that the universe
isn’t built to our measure
but operates on systems
beyond our perception.
That what we call empty air
is anything but empty.
If you're a bat,
it holds the sound
of the shape of a hillside.
It's also a map of magnetic signals
and electrical fields.
And a topography of the smells
of krill patches and plankton blooms.
We humans have invented
whole digital worlds,
but sometimes we still need to be reminded
that there’s more in this heaven and Earth
than is dreamt of in our philosophy.
And that there are endless ways
to look at familiar sights,
like a bird in flight, with fresh eyes.
To expand our shared experience
in a way that connects us
with the rest of the living world.
To feel both kinship
with our fellow creatures
and respect and even reverence
for their otherness.
In the words of the poet
and naturalist Jarod K. Anderson,
bats can hear shapes,
plants can eat light,
bees can dance maps.
We can hold all these ideas at once
and feel both heavy and weightless
with the absurd beauty of it all.
Thank you.
(Applause)